30 bruce james
and lindsay mack not to be confused with
lindsay out
um rather a small agenda today um i've
got to be gone by nine
because i have a specialist appointment
in the hospital
so if we go up to that time um
i was going to call in my lieutenant but
i won't now um
our speedy expert down here will will
deputize and take over so um
so we just work quickly through the
agenda on on routine matters do we have
any apologies
yes
nobody bruce look i i have been talking
on the cooking i've been texting
with richard hardy today and uh james
as in substitute for him richards had to
go to uh cautionary work at um
this morning
that's one step better than going to the
antarctic i suppose isn't it
you're probably right yeah anyway uh
james j i'd like i like us to welcome
james but just recognize richard's uh
richard's been otherwise engaged yep
thank you
and i see james on doomy
do we have a link from um claire from
lindsay abbott who
counselor ever has apologised for all
meetings this week transfer avatar's not
a member of the just raise that because
he was going to report back on an issue
yep that's fine
any any notification of the urgent
business
there being nothing
um
we'll just move on to the agenda
and the minutes from the previous
meeting so if somebody would who was
present would like to
i welcome your worship
and
would like to
recommend that that be accepted
thank you
a second up
were you here um
no you you know you know you went jeff
you're going to put your hand up now
thank you please pay attention
um
is there any discussion or matters
arising from the previous minutes
there being none i'll put that to vote
all those in favor all right all right
all right carried
moving on to the project update report
and
take this is uh your area of expertise
jane
uh thank you
nobby
as as we said it's a reasonably um short
agenda i think there's three key items
in this report that the group will want
to focus on
these are supporting the mayor's working
group which is section three
incorporating the charter work in
section four
and the six monthly review in section
five
so perhaps we move to page seven and
section three mr chair would that be the
way to go can there be fine thinking
and there's a paragraph there which will
take us red
and as you've already said a variable
update will be provided at the meeting
i'm not sure who's
going to do that yeah i can probably
help with that jane um at the cheers
meeting on
on monday i asked his worship whether he
was still interested in this group and
he gave an undertaking at that meeting
that he would ring the council as
concerned
um i think there were four or five
councils named
um
to gauge their support for a formal or
informal support group
so i don't know where that's gone to and
i might ask his worship if he's
had any result in that area because that
group just seems to linger and we don't
seem to be going anywhere so
to move you have yet made contact with
those those are elected members who
potentially were going to be in that
group that supported you i think it was
scalp
arnold
abbott
graeme lewis of this one
councillor ludlow oh yes thank you
how did you get with that tom
um
no it was a lot harder than i thought
because
meeting
that we had
all through yesterday
and
and um
i realize then
how difficult it is to
get a group of that size within a
short period of
time and
that
i suppose
one of the reasons is that i don't have
a pa
except for the
um
12 hour or 14 hours i think that allowed
me to have
staff help
and but i'm prepared to make a list of
all the
help that i need and greater detail
um just to help clarify for your
perspective jane um i might ask
councillors skilled
and lewis whether they got a telephone
call from the mayor since monday on the
issue
i haven't received one no that's not
cheering
i even received no and so jane i guess
this is the we're back to square round
where we were at before
about um
and i will ask um
lindsay who's on zoom shortly to talk to
us potentially as well
um is you know what's the benefit to be
gained by keeping this group going and
i've
worked considerably behind the scenes to
try and get a support group up and
running for the mayor so that he feels
supported at work
um i did that informally to start with
with the counselors mentioned and i got
a very positive response
it's fair to say that
following discussion with that group of
counsellors
there was a media released by the mayor
which
unhinged the support for that from that
group from some members who felt a bit
betrayed by it
um and so i guess it's uh it's where we
keep that group going and what support
there will be for it at the chairs
meeting when i asked on monday is
worship whether he wanted to continue to
have that group he said yes but he was
quite definitive that he didn't want any
of the members of the cheers group to be
involved so that excludes me and um
because of my relationship issues i
guess with him and so um
we left it in his ball cart
in his domain to um ring around and
find out whether it was going to be
support and whether that support would
be informal or formal so i guess that's
what we got to jane and it doesn't help
your
your scenario because we just keep
pushing this issue
yeah
yes and i think the last the last thing
to comment about that which we did talk
about at the chairs group as well
was even if we had that group of support
formally in the system what goals and
outcomes
and measures are we going to put in
place so how will we know that we're
getting any traction or is it just a bit
of a talk fest
and so that was the sort of second layer
that kicked in as well so can i just um
listen just suggest that we go back to
what was discussed at the last meeting
that councillor abbott was to be
requested
on behalf of ptg to
talk to those in
yes i i i did both ring and email onesie
but as you'll know he's had a breath in
the family recently and he i think he's
not being well either okay um
so whether he's had difficulty around
that i'm not i'm not sure i've tried to
contact him again the last couple of
days
um
just to express my regrets about it but
also to catch up with him and i haven't
had a response which is unlikely he
normally does come i suggest then that
we seek for a counselor but to
um
report to the next cheers group
okay
can i can i can i support that i think
um
now that you've made that comment um
counsellor
it reduces that group to four because
one of the members who volunteered as a
member of cheers group so that reduces
it to four which
which changes what the mayor said about
it being a too large group um so i think
it's quite valid that we
that we
um
go back to asking councillor abbott to
see what he can arrange
claire's got a mouth half open so just
before she says something
just for your benefit leslie i'm i
wasn't part of this group i just
coordinated to start with the names so
with me being out
one of them
is group
so that reduces the the group down sure
mr chair i'm sorry i don't believe
councillor ludlow was ever included the
cheers group notes councillors kit
abbott lewis scout and arnold yes
i don't believe there was ever a
discussion about councillor lewis no
there wasn't i am aware that councillor
abbott has had no contact with his
worship for the last two months okay
so i just wondered just to try and
expedite taking uh mr grover's point
that i mean there's two of us here today
this worship could take the opportunity
after this meeting and discuss it with
us yeah to try and progress the process
sure personal point of view i'm still
very happy to support me either
informally or or formally but i think we
need to expediate the process but if
indeed it's going to happen so sure so
mr chair can i be presumptuous and ask
could we move that request to councillor
scout
to have that discussion this afternoon
and report back through the chairs group
next week happy for that to happen here
as long as councillor um
he will be fine i am sure he will be
fine okay thank you yeah that's fine
thank you for that counselor
right let's uh
here's something on the first one um the
next one headed up section for the
council charter and you'll recall that
last time
the group asked that we make sure that
the work of the um
around the council charter be
incorporated into this project and we've
noted there to make sure and it is in
fact one of the foundation documents but
we don't want anything to fall between
the cracks and keep the momentum going
um we were provided with some notes from
the session so um
i wasn't nor was the secretariat party
to any of the workshops but we'd we were
at pains in these bullet points not to
change any of the the wording
from the notes that's why it might look
a little bit cumbersome but hopefully
there's the seven bullet points there
if we could work through them
um there's a suggestion that i think the
things like workshops can be direct
the um one two three for the fifth one
and the seventh ones where we're we're
monitoring things
um
the secretariat wondered whether they
could be incorporated into the
outcomes monitoring table which we have
on this agenda and which we talk about
every time
so i i guess we open it up and perhaps
work through
each bullet point
and then
the group might want to identify whether
there's anything that's critically
missing
would that be a way to handle this one
nobody yeah that would be fine yeah we
can go through that by the bullet points
yes and i think we're all mindful
that there will be an election in
october so we've got to think about that
as we consider these days
so the first ones
was in fact to
[Music]
put something in the diary for the
incoming council
in november
there was a suggestion
that um we review ask them to review and
adopt
that didn't come out of the workshop but
that's the first point so i guess is
november sensible
do we want them to review it do we want
them to
formally adopt it um over to the the
team
some ideas on it people clear
mr chair i wonder whether uh in november
the uh
incoming council won't be sworn in until
later in october
and to say in november would make this
one of the very first things and frank
be interesting to get your point of view
as an incoming elected member
whether working on the charter would be
one of the first things you'd want to do
or whether
having
other parts of the induction program
which is a necessary part of
the pgg's review later this year
whether it should just be noted to be
held within the first quarter to be able
to get your views sure yeah as a
first-time counsellor
i think i think that's one of the things
that was missing i guess when i first
came into council we went through a lot
of induction very quickly
um but the culture of the charter wasn't
there
and so that undermines not not
not the induction process which is how
we physically do things but it's more
about how our behavior should be as
counsellors
and how you how you engage new people
into a into a culture that's already
there
and tolerate that so i think
i'm very supportive of having it very
early on in the process
any other views on that can i just say
not as a first-time counsellor but as as
a
counselor who've been here for a while
that i think it's actually
useful to have it early in the process
for new councillors who aren't
necessarily aware that there is a
charter or exactly what it says i think
as councillor clarks just pointed out
that it's actually a good thing to
introduce it at the earliest stage we
can so
i'd be quite supportive
of november i mean i know it's a busy
time but i think all new councillors
expect it to be a busy time for
induction
and finding out about things like the
culture and
just the way the organization operates
so
yeah i tend to think um now that we have
it and it's been socialised to some
extent that it would be good to
have it in the in the very earliest
part of the whole induction process okay
thank you for that
all right jane that gives you a steer on
that one okay we've got that one the
next one is a practical one too you are
very busy so we have to think ahead in
terms of dieting
and sessions so
what was suggested was february march
and february's about gone so
two before october
so just on a personal level i i didn't
attend the last one
i was away
um
so i don't know what transpired there
but
in my mindset having a charter
a dedicated session in july august and
as flogging to death a little bit
given that we will be in the election
mode
um it's hard to get a uniform unified um
behaviour pattern out of councillors
when we're all lobbying to retain
positions or take each other's positions
i think that the latter one
um does not have merit for me i think
we'll we'll set ourselves up to fail on
that one whether you want one before
then that's up to others to decide
because i wasn't at the last one so i
don't know what stage we got to jay
others who were who there might
use the nigel or
yes
yeah sure i agree with you
the july august one is from the dead
course because you're going to have
perhaps four or five councils that won't
stand for reflection i'm just going to
have to redo the work later yeah with
the new council so it seems a little bit
of waste of time sure
that's but you're at the last one
does there need to be another one going
forward do you think
march april jane's right uh february's
probably although it's only the
beginning of february january
february is probably not realistic now
but march april i think would be
um
would be worthwhile
to plan for i was at the last one and i
think it would be
it would be useful to keep the momentum
going but i take on board what the other
two have said about
that close to the
coming election
is probably not practical
and nigel were you at the last one you
know what um i just wonder it's it's
about the timing of it and also the
practicality and what we want to achieve
from it to be honest
and given the points the other
councillors have said i just wonder
about them so we got to a position in
your mind that we're sort of okay where
we're at the moment or do we need some
more reinforcement by way of a workshop
i'm okay
okay
graham's okay leslie
i'd be comfortable with one in march
april
as part of the ongoing
[Music]
bearding in really okay
so you've got to steer on that jane
yeah that's good
the next two um
one's the induction program the second
one's the professional development
program
but the key thing is to include
bicultural competency
learning and
again explicit on culture building
and i think
we had a review of what's actually in
the professional development program
and i think we've got plans in that area
and
the induction program as i say is a
separate thing but similar
content needed so just a bit of a steer
on these two
i think the team next one yep um i'll
just give an initial view to you on on
that jane um
and i've got a background in
corporate training
um and this is a very sensitive issue
this issue of biculturalism and whether
you need to
train people up
um
my view
is that in induction you should have
some
initial not learning but initial
expectation from the organization on
what skill set you want around
biculturalism
and then you have a professional
development program that allows people
to engage where they may not have that
so for argument's sake
would a person that was very strong on
biculturalism
or has a background in organizations
that have already trained them on would
they be compelled to go forward past an
induction program into it and wouldn't
be seen
negatively if they didn't and so um
one of the things about professional
development so it doesn't just become a
rubber stamp and people are
forced to come
um is it's got to be on a personal level
that's what personal professional
development's all about so having an
induction is great
and then that allows people people to
self-identify there's a skill set here
that i don't have and therefore i need
to seek some professional development
that goes with it
open the views of other people
cheers
certainly
the white culture the actual word
competency you can sit at the meeting
and not be comfortable can you take your
mask off when you talk
sit in the meeting and not be confident
you can put your way through
yeah show how you're going to actually
measure that someone actually has sat
through and got a competency level yep
and you're quite right i've been in the
organizations in the state sector where
we've had two rio lessons once a month
for about two years and if i went back a
year after that most of people
uh were stroked still struggling with it
so you're right you can sit there and
participate but not actually pick it up
um so there's a manual of some such
well it's
you've got to show the commitment and
and what we did in the state sector was
we we engaged everybody they had no
choice
and the ones that picked up the most are
the ones that really wanted it and so
that's where your professional
development comes in it's a little bit
like you could argue that to be in this
job you've got to be able to read a
financial spreadsheet well there's some
that can't i know that um
but it's not the end of the in the world
if they can't but it shows that they're
inefficient in that area when it comes
to debate around finance or whatever
so the hints that the two stage you
bring an induction this is what we
expect you to have an understanding of
and here's the opportunity to gain the
knowledge if you don't already have it
um
and i would have thought because um
um
because our state
uh the government is pushing really hard
on ontario and other things cultural
then i would expect an incoming mayor um
to sit with each council individually
and work through some of these issues
and saying you know what is your
background what is your knowledge
can you do this at a mirai can you speak
some degree to rio where needed and if
not and encourage them to go to the
professional development
can i just say i think both of these are
just too important to have there as part
of their culture
um to
not continue with the path they take on
board what the others are saying some
people will
pick up a great deal more than others
but the fact that we are showing the
commitment to having this embedded into
our programs i think is the principle
here
you know can i also add um
uh probably fitted trader even here but
um i think also we have to think
seriously about not just
um our protocols which is perhaps if i
could uh minimize what you're saying to
things like being able to speak torreira
or would you be comfortable on a mirai
i think actually all councillors will
need to understand actually the
increasing
uh and changing arrangements
particularly between ewe
and the act whether that's local
government act whether that's the
resource management act when you pile on
top of that resource management act
reform
or three waters reform as you folk will
be well and truly aware i think there's
actually quite a fundamental
set of training that at any council
um and to usual words expectations must
be
at least aware of the trends and
understand what's happening
so that it can be grafted into their
governance
process and protocols so um i think
actually this is this is probably a
really big area um which requires any
council in the cargo included to think
seriously about how it it moves that
induction i would say from that
i would be looking very strongly then
how do you build the individual
competency sets and then the
individualized development program that
you're talking about
i think that's a big part we've got to
take into account lobby
yeah appreciate all that and that's what
i was alluding to that we do have a
changing landscape with central
government
and it's not just the the labor
government it will be right across the
government sector that there is
expectation that we have greater
competency in some of these areas
so i think you've got to stare there
jane on
that bullet point and the next one that
follows yeah these two
no
the the next one
that's the one i was suggesting that we
need to incorporate into our
monitoring table i think i um well first
of all
i guess the question for the team are
does this make sense do you want to do
that and then following on from that
therefore where do we put it so
therefore where do we put it
would be the monitoring table unless
anybody's got a better idea
seems straightforward jane and the best
place for it to go
okay moving on
next one will
yes we'll do that so that's clear that
we need to
incorporate the earnings into our legacy
report
and finally the last one again
this is one where we've got a bit of
monitoring in place in terms of looking
at our council reports and making sure
they're fit for purpose
and so on so we could
incorporate that into the the same
system
to make sure that we do that yep
i don't think there's any disagreement
with that okay
so unless um anybody who actually we're
at the the workshops thinks we've missed
anything
um we can give a tip to that section i
think
okay
the six monthly review again we've
already agreed there'll be two parts
we'll repeat the quantitative survey and
we'll ask brood bruce to
lead a more qualitative open-ended
review
in terms of 5.1 the questions
that were asked last time
are attached i would like to just
emphasize to you that when we did them
we
they were designed in a way that we
could repeat them so that we see whether
we've progressed but i do know
that
nobody you in particular but perhaps
others would like to discuss these
questions our suggestion is
minor changes take out the open-ended
ones and make sure they're covered and
bruce's work
but over to the team for what you want
to do so i'll raise this before leslie
goes because i know we're getting very
close to her deadline um
i raised two issues with you jane so not
everybody will know that the two issues
were that um i was a little bit nervous
about changing too many questions
because then the comparative between the
last surveillance survey gets a little
bit blurred
um yeah but i was specifically uneasy
about questions um
45 47 and 48 so they are around comms
and so they they imply how well are we
doing on it on issues of communications
and it was asked us to write
um or suggesting that the
way forward and you had to comment on on
it
was that um and using me as an example
that if i wanted to make any statement
to the media
i had to
let my colleagues know first
and secondly um i needed to gauge their
views
and i'm not sure why i gaze their views
because trying to get 13 members to get
some commonality on that would be
fraught with problems um i i don't
understand what we're trying to get out
there
and i'm sure his worship and i will
probably both jump to our feet at some
point and say this is a gagging order
um
but we don't have the comms policy out
yet
and so
we have the democratic right under the
local government act for me to say what
i like
i don't need a canvas with us so long as
i express it as a personal view not as a
council view um to those three questions
um leave me a personally a little bit
unhinged about what we're trying to
achieve there and what we're now
engaging by one of the questions so
that's just my personal feedback
it was a deathly silence
yes jeff
sorry could i just ask oh sorry uh one
of these
questions is the last one
sorry did you want to contribute there
leslie oh just very quickly what i was
going to say is i'm i would also be
reluctant to to change lots of the
questions i understand about the
open-ended questions jane and i agree
with that um but
the ones that nobby has raised i think
it's probably important actually to
leave them in there and allow
counsellors
for instance you counselor clark
to
express your view as i'm sure
was done previously and
i think that's part of the
the comparison between the first survey
and the survey
so i'm i'm not sure that we need to take
any more out as such i think probably i
guess where i come a little bit unhinged
with that leslie is
and claire's laughing at me
um
is it the survey by nature asks you to
rank it it's not a sort of 137 but at
one end it says strongly agree with the
statement the other end strongly
disagree with the statement is and so it
doesn't give me an opportunity actually
to say the statement's actually wrong
um
it breaches my rights under the local
government act to speak publicly if i
want to um
so yeah i was unsure about that but i
hear what you're saying and we do have
an option with uh bruce's survey to
feedback on that as well
i think uh navi that um i tend to agree
with leslie that that it would be good
to keep these in here but your point as
well may that i think um with the
absence of a media protocol
uh and in it probably being one of the
remaining challenges for council as a
whole that would be a it would be a
reasonable part of whatever um
we prepare for the the qualitative
reviews so i think we i'd argue keep
this and we'll also pick it up in terms
of the final review
yeah i think i i think um sorry i'll
have to go count to a quite but yeah i
think i would be more comfortable to
leave it in so that the comparison
between the two stays
as valid as possible but also that it's
picked up in bruce's
work
which would then
give any anyone including yourself the
chance to have that
further
feedback
thank you sorry everyone i will have to
yeah
yeah thank you
have a good day okay thank
are the views around the table on the
quantum quantitative survey
deathly science well i think it is what
it is and we need to get on with it
real danger we have as you being
unhinged to be fair
and we've known that for quite a few
times very very poor english you you
should have said more counselors
so get yourself hinged
the only thing i want to say is yet i
definitely agree in terms of changing
too many questions because yeah you lose
that that comparability yeah yeah thank
you for that
so i guess this is what for me
personally i think this is the one area
of the thompson report that we still
haven't got a good handle on which is
our media exposure and how that works
um
we've talked about having a principle of
no surprises which i've always had i
always give counselors a heads up when
i'm going to say something in the media
so they don't read about it in the media
but we don't always get that back from
the staff media exposure either so
that's an area um uh mayor to his credit
has been
um very positive in the last three or
four months
on medium we haven't had a lot of
negative stuff so that's good for us
going forward
but still still some work to be done and
some underlying
uh work that dovetails with the charter
as well i think about the culture of the
way we we expose ourselves both
individually and collectively
and and while you can do both i think
you sometimes can
not using the word unhinged but you can
under into the picture of the collective
if one or two uh shoot off on a on a
tangent so
so i think you've got to stare there
jane about the uh
questions in
if i can just pick up what you actually
said it does
um
dovetail with the chart and now the
media stuff so well we've got a good
steer there now we need a steer on
question 44. in the last survey we had
five
um
what would we call them contentious
issues
the issue is do you want to add on
another couple or confine them to two or
three or four
so bruce has done a runner for his uh
worry about his folder somewhere else he
hit it off to something else um
can you can you refresh the memory of
what 44 says jane
44
says um
contentious issues
how are the council progressing on
coming to agreement on the following
issues and then it's simply a list
and i'll tell you the list central city
redevelopment the water tower esque
street rugby park and anderson house
that was last time in the museum and we
had the museum
yep
what do you want to have this time well
i i suggested my feedback to you jane
that we should
exclude some of those because they're
too far off into the distance
certainly the water towers schedule for
next term or the termite council's made
a decision to finish the design and
pause that
so the museum is still a contiguous
issue and we're working on that at the
moment and and and i thought we should
include three waters as well the three
water reform issue
so mr chair i'd have to ask about that
one in the sense that i'm not sure
council is in control of three waters
reform if you look at that list there is
there that's a list of council projects
okay
um but three waters reform is quite
frankly a government
issue which might be on their list of
contentious issues
and more and more mandated as well too
clear so there's even less room and
scope for
discussion
it's not a political statement it's just
reality
um cheer just uh perhaps a comment about
the question um
it's headed contentious issues but what
they really are now are strategic
priorities they were contentious
in the beginning but subsequent to the
council of agreeing on what priorities
were they are shouldn't be contentious
anymore they should they they are your
priorities
so i wonder if at the risk of
you know creating a little bit of a
disconnect between the first
questionnaire and the second whether the
heading can be changed to reflect what
these issues actually are now as opposed
to what they were yeah
yes i'm getting nodding around the table
on that one jane
okay
and museum and and three waters out
no no no no
i believe the museum yes i see the
museum in but the three waters one is
out yeah
no
um i'll just have to put up some more
signs around town here
so we've got
what about the water tower
that's out that's out yeah
it's too far into the future
central city redevelopment street
obviously
that's current mr chair can i just say
i'm a little uncomfortable about those
being in and the reason i'm a little
uncomfortable relates to timing we're
currently consulting on further
investment
and it feels a little
muddy
to be
um surveying counsellors on a matter
that is open for consultation for which
you'll be asked to bring an open mind
into your decision making yeah
good and i agree with that jane i think
we have icl in place that delivers that
and we are in the consultation process
as well
okay
rugby park
my personal views that shouldn't be in
because it's it's off into the future
still
we've got it operational um
but there's not a [ __ ] there's not a
short-term resolution here
maybe for next council
is that everybody agreeing with that
yep right
anderson hose
that has been resolved we are
strengthening it we are making it
watertight the work stops there
yeah well we've really cut it back now
we've got central city redevelopment and
museum uh and central city redevelopment
shouldn't be in there either
i think the museum wow
so jane sorry just can you just remind
me of the timing for the survey
march
now remember the question is how are
council progressing on coming to
agreement and is it a multi-choice
answer
no it's not it's one of these ones where
you scale it i think
okay yeah that's sorry that's what i
meant it's a scale from one to ten it's
a scale and it was it was more about
whether council going through a mature
process of
um
what's the word prioritizing what they
want to do
do
so jane do we have a date so the only
reason i'm asking is because the museum
will be included in the draft annual
plan
and so my comments
my comments about central city
redevelopment and esk street were made
because we are consulting right now
and we will be
making decisions around the same sort of
time
um in the same vein we'll be going out
for the draft annual plan
around the time that we are answering
that question on the museum
the museum is the one that would remain
as the most contentious and not yet
resolved
but i'd just like to be careful in terms
of consultation
process i um noticed a bit james you may
be able to help us here because you're
the you're the man on surveys
um
as to whether uh what would happen if we
were even to exclude this because it
comes under section 10 which is called
complaints
and i take on board
um
why that would hits question 44 to being
there when you think about the original
position we were all in when richard did
his first review
but
i think lindsay's points well made
that that we have i think removed it
from being contentious issues
not necessarily in terms of decisions
made but to being one around strategic
priorities
so i don't know how much it still
relates to the area of complaints that's
really the point i'm trying to make and
whether in fact it warrants even having
pushed in there now on reflection uh
looking at it
and james i mentioned your name because
i try to think ways in which this
wouldn't invalidate our report i just
wonder if we were to exclude 44 in total
whether this should be a different
question more in line with lindsay's
how do we deal with our differences
around strategic priorities
um i'd certainly agree in terms of the
fact that if some of these have already
been resolved or in the process of being
resolved well then the decisions have
kind of essentially been made so
if we're going to keep taking things out
then it does lessen the
the um importance of that question
because you're only left with one or two
things left
um i i don't think there'd be any harm
in taking it out but i do think yeah
possibly rewording it as
well for some of them anyway as
strategic then that might get to address
some of those that are still remaining
but if so many of them are coming out
because they're either too far in the
future or they've already been resolved
and there's there's probably no point
so so my reflection on that bruce is
that we should take it out
and not replace it because the only i
guess
from my specific the only contentious
issue is the museum and it's not
actually the progress we've made to date
is not actually
what we're delivering in the in museum
space
um i'm probably one of the greatest
the centers i guess on the museum issue
but what i see in front of me is
actually okay it's the time framing
of the project and the fact that the
storage
um
and the museum demolition
uh
are not dovetail
there are one leads from the other and
that's that so that's the issue this is
not what we're delivering it's just the
timing and so uh
i don't see any dissension anywhere else
in our ranks on uh
on the other projects that we're working
through
anderson's houses on uh
is on schedule and looks really good
that was the other big contentious one
with the public
those two museum and anderson's house
well i think i'd be saying nobody would
take it out yep
44 goes agreed
thank you
sorry i had to disappear there was a
gust of min wind and i lost you um next
thing i've heard it called many things
we didn't pick that up jane
yeah yep um
now the last survey this is the next
paragraph
we asked external appointees chief
executive elt
as well as the mayor and elected members
there was
some of the questions were inappropriate
for some of these people to
answer and we didn't get
but
a lot of
that
it wasn't um we are i'm stumbling now i
lost my stride i think that this time we
should just ask the elected members and
councillors because that's who the
questions apply to
um
not people like
me for instance some of them just simply
didn't make sense
so what you get was
um no answer so you get a very small
sample so the suggestion is that we um
and we were able to pull out the data
set for just the elected members and the
mayor last time
and so we're suggesting that this time
that's what we do
and we're not think that claire has the
opportunity in the open-ended review to
contribute thoughts that she might have
sure clear uh mr grant and i would be
happy to agree with that suggestion
yeah i think we all got feedback jane
last time around that uh some of the elt
members yeah struggled with the survey
because it didn't apply to them
that's right okay well that's clear so
we've got a steer on that one
and that takes us on to i think anybody
any more issues you want to bring up on
the
impact survey
if not
we will confirm the questions back to
them by the end of this week and you'll
start to get some um comms on this
coming out
shortly
the open-ended review um what we've done
there is summarize the four key issues
that came out last time
um
a suggestion that there's an opportunity
to raise anything else
um and we've already
added in something about the media
and stuff i i know that clear has a
suggestion to add in something but
perhaps
i'm
given bruce is sitting here
if i pass over to bruce
to talk about what what the
review includes and also how
he wants to go about it
yeah thanks um
jane i um
it's um yet another review isn't it and
um
uh i don't want to dismiss it as a
result i think it's actually really
important quite critical
um i have a bigger sense of the
objective and mind here um and we've
also talked about there being
uh legacy reports so there's a sense in
which
um certainly uh perhaps more talking in
the corridors rather than formally
there's a sense to which we want us we
want to see
whether the original four themes we've
got here and i look i take on board
issues around uh media etc uh need to be
added
in but whether we have made progress or
more importantly solved them and there's
an important test have we solved them to
the point that the department
could now express confidence in us
because i think that's actually the goal
that we want by
let's say 30 gene
so um that says that i think uh the
basis of my thinking
and working with jane on this is that
actually we go back to what were the
original problems that we saw
with our organization and you'll recall
these four themes came out
uh
after we received the letter from the
department
and that initial approach that i was
asked to take is the independent advisor
the council to say what are the issues
that that we are facing and these are
the four themes
so i think we need to have a a short
process
um and jan and i have been talking about
this probably by direct interview with
elected members
as to whether we've
nailed these
that is actually the critical part to it
so in terms of method
um we base on this um it is it needs to
be open-ended so if it does need to be
the capacity to say well we may have
moved on these we may have opened the
other
other issues
the media protocol was clearly being
mentioned today and uh clear i'm aware
that i think you suggested another area
be
included as well
but i think that's the way we would want
to do it
second
part to method is not only by way of
direct interview
but the second the second part is
actually
generally anticipating we should do this
uh commencing at least by the last week
in february
so that we've got time to nail this and
move it reasonably quickly
so that i think it's early april
uh the pgg can actually adopt a report
so i think those are the sort of key
points from my perspective of the stage
jamie
thank you and a claire's
suggestion on i know she can make it for
herself but it was can you include
something about what have people learnt
yes almost
so from what just to give you some
feedback from my viewpoint bruce i think
these are still critical issues
um
all the work we're doing still has the
questions of leadership and how we're
working together
and whether we have leadership in
traditional areas or not
um
and so i've seen progress in all these
areas
and i've seen a little bit of slippage
in them in the media one
so i think it would be helpful uh
one-on-one is the best way forward for
me
i think um coming and talking to
councillors collectively is not the way
forward
if you schedule half an hour for each
councillor
and some don't turn up soviet um
but it would be helpful and i think that
would
nicely lead into a report that then goes
back to dia that then challenges them to
say well we've done as much as we can do
in this term
given that we're leading up to the silly
season where
we'll probably cut each other's throats
a little bit
on some issues but are we performing
okay and i i get a lot of
um
feedback that says that we've made some
significant progress
including from dia but it would be nice
to have that um formally suggested so
that we get some affirmation that we've
done the right thing
i think from department perspective that
that yeah certainly addressing those
those four initial issues and and being
clear on what progress that's been made
would be really really important because
that that was the reason for the whole
reason that we're sitting here sure
thing with bruce
sorry lindsey i missed that can you just
repeat yes i just want to check
something with bruce if i could
so i
totally understand and accept the
reasoning for the eas not in the elt and
others not participating in the
quantitative survey absolutely
valid points there just a question bruce
as to whether you are intending uh input
from jeff and myself into the open-ended
review
like yeah i realized when i just said
counselors i was being a bit
exclusionary because i think
we
actually
in the paper here uh mayor councillor
chief executive and i think it should
also include the eas clearly you guys
have been
um pivotal to our response
um and and uh while you're not uh
commissioners in other words a direct
line to the minister as it might be the
case in tehran
you've got a direct line to us so we
need to know what you guys are really
thinking
um
so
that would be also pivotal so yes eas
must be in my view
i'm looking around the table for
confirmation on that
yep getting getting nodding everywhere
on that one jane
[Music]
and we just leave you bruce to
the liaise with jane to schedule those
interviews
yes
um
not not in front of claire but i have
asked that jane be able to be involved
in this so that we can do this
expeditiously
so that we roll it out fast
thank you
yes do you worship
yes i think out of those four the one
that i'm most involved in is the issue
of leadership
and it really does need to
[Music]
focus at some stage
what our
methods will be used to
dissolve this one and get some sort of
consensus
what what was the list of the
four out of the big four
we've identified
where did leadership come in
you know i can help you with that your
worship um
so in the original thompson report that
was one of the issues raised
he said that um we had a lack of
leadership from the mayoral role
and so i guess this this work that bruce
and jane are doing is saying well
um
it's very easy to sit back and say that
me is not performing to a certain level
but any good team
looks at leadership from different
perspectives as well so
from a
community perspective as long as the
results are there and
it doesn't matter whether the mayor
drives a result or whether it's a
collective leadership role
so long as a degree of dysfunction there
at the end of the day it's all about
tangible outcomes
and certainly i've been very vocal about
most the issues on this list
but i can't deny that we've got some
very good tangible outcomes for the city
and some more in front of us
so i think the other thing that we ought
to add here by the way is that these
four points are the list that we
ourselves derived they weren't richards
i mean there is clearly a high
congruence between richard's initial
report
at these four points but these four
themes i think we've been calling them
were issues
we're actually those were notified by
councillors
as a collective
um so that's why these are so important
because when we started this process in
response to the department's leader
these were the issues that were in front
of us and so
tim
the the first one was the absence of
effective leadership among to members
that was felt generally by the
by the by the elected members as a whole
so there's a very real question
how have we progressed on that and
that's something which this report
notice review report should try and
address
and as you reflected bruce the sooner
the better um
this sort of uh
discussion coming forward at election
time or close to election time not going
to be helpful for us
people have protracted positions around
this
and will be defensive of comments so
and that's why we that's why i said uh
nobby um uh i think uh given the program
that has been that that we have agreed
as a pgj yeah joe and i would be aiming
to have a a draft report for the
committee on the about the 3rd of april
4th of april
anyway um lobby so that's the that's the
reason we're saying we need to start
that this this month so that we can have
something credible for you in early
april to adopt
six months before the election
and then following from that the legacy
report will come through in may and the
findings will be incorporated into that
total
yep
thank you
any other questions
everybody's shaking their head
okay
that's your report done
we're done people uh yeah sorry do you
want to work through the
table six i don't know if michael morris
is i can't see michael he's here
he's here right well michael has updated
this
um there may be questions on it rather
than going through line by line
yep
so as as michael's putting his finger on
on section six i have to leave so
this is yours jeff thank you
i can't afford anybody where did you go
so are there any uh
comments or questions in regard to table
six which is the report against outcomes
which michael's updated
any questions
hoping that's all relatively
self-evident that's good
thanks mark
seven draft work plan
that's reasonably straightforward i
think
budget update underwrite
which is looking well under budget
project risk
from the project directorate
so the risk register are there any
noting that is a closed item
any questions
appear to be none can we move on to
communications update
no there's a uh
um
an apology from lisa yep that she was
the
committee to know that the com strategy
has been endorsed by elt
and
it's now with the organization for any
other feedback and clearly update if
there's anything other than that
we're planning a counselor workshop on
march the first and that will also
inform the training program
and um
for the um comms and media staff
any questions around comms
can we note uh the next meetings on the
second of march
are there any other matters
just note the the last part of the
meeting went very quickly thank you
thank you
you